let's look at all the offers that I've
ever had in my life we'll just go
through the offers in tech because um
you guys probably don't care about the
fact that I worked at McDonald's even
though that McDonald was a pretty fine
job I don't want to brag but what was a
top performing employee actually that's
not true I was the worst and why because
I didn't care I don't really care about
my job I mean McDonald that's like a low
tier company you know a high chair
company would be like in and out if I
didn't get an offer from them so you
know it's the reason why I like wearing
hats so much because it reminds me of
the good old times the humble beginnings
of Joma Tech now let's go through the
tech offers now I want to explain that I
went to University of Waterloo the best
school in Canada it's basically like MIT
but for Canada in Waterloo we usually
have to do five to six internships one
semester at school one semester you do
an internship one semester at school one
semester you're at internship blah blah
blah so the system in which we apply to
jobs is called job mine apparently now
it's called Waterloo works or something
like that but so in job mine they record
all of your job application actually
they only remember of the ones that you
had an interview for and then you could
either have three things either you're
not ranked it means the company does not
want you at all or you are ranked
because some companies they only hire
maybe one intern for the season and then
because they only hire one intern what
they do is that they rank the
interviewees okay so this is my first
co-op job I think I was a I was a
freshman right right after freshmen
usually your first co-op term your first
internship it's pretty bad it's pretty
bad everyone in Canada or in Waterloo
wants to go to Cali we have something
called Cali or bust
it means you either go to California to
get a job or you bust meaning you just
get nothing which is kind of a risky
move it means you just apply
to all California jobs because that's
you know Silicon Valley and then if you
don't get any job you're pretty [ __ ]
all right so let's check it out so this
was my first ever coop and here you go I
had one two three four five six seven
eight nine ten eleven
I had eleven interviews note that I
applied to 50 jobs because 50 was the
maximum so I applied to 50 jobs and then
I had one two three four five six six
ranked or offer one two three four I had
four offer and two ranked now let's look
at the unranked one real quick look at
this talent here I got Palantir
interview for my first term which is
pretty crazy now usually they only hire
seniors which is true cuz they didn't
hire me but then again I was extremely
unqualified for it
you know I just started coding I didn't
know anything about software engineering
but I got pretty damn far because I
think what I did was um they came to to
our school to talk about Palantir and
stuff like that and then I started
talking or chatting with one of the
person he was a Ford deploying engineer
and apparently he was from Montreal - I
said oh I'm from Montreal - blah blah
blah blah blah blah and then we bonded
over that and then he was able to get me
an interview which is very rare but yeah
and then I passed the phone interview
and they were quite impressed but then
once I got to be on-site it's not really
an on-site they actually come to
Waterloo to data interview they asked me
a systems question I'll say yeah there's
no [ __ ] way I know anything like I
didn't know anything about computers
back then I didn't know anything about
software engineering so yeah I felt it
easy-peasy yeah so like the first jobs
you usually get like QA positions or you
know shibi positions and that's exactly
what I got as you see QA for Bank of
America and then I did not get
quantitative research while that must be
a really hardcore job
quantitative research macro mode Shaw
didn't get that desire to learn oh
that's actually a good first company to
be at in Waterloo but didn't get that oh
but I got the QA version the QA
developer for it but I did not take that
Indiana I
Scotiabank because as analysts credit
and equity derivatives that's actually a
financial engineering position so I've
had friends that went there and it's a
pretty legit job my friends were seniors
or juniors and they had this job so to
get it as a freshman I was pretty proud
so I took that job and then if we go to
the second year as a sophomore as you
can see I got one two three three offers
one ranked and then one two three four
five five rejection out of all of these
interviews so this one I was actually
pretty happy I worked pretty hard for it
and fortunately I got a lot of these
finance / tech jobs so as you can see I
was still in finance I got an offer from
Bloomberg that was like the first offer
I got and I was quite happy because
Bloomberg for our second co-op is pretty
legit I think because I want to go to
America I even told my advisor I said I
want to go to America
but then my advisor told me no you
shouldn't do that that's that's a stupid
decision to make you're not gonna get it
honestly [ __ ] that guy if I listen to
him I probably wouldn't have been you
know working at these nice companies
nowadays but yeah he literally said yeah
don't even think about it
that is so disrespectful so what I did
was I applied to only American jobs so
it's kind of like Kali or bus but
instead it's America or bust and look at
that I got three offers from us Oh
actually actually it's more than just
three offer I actually got quantitative
brokers too but the thing about
employers is sometimes they call you
they say oh do you want this offer if
not then I'm not gonna I'm not gonna
rank you I'm not gonna offer you because
it's kind of like a game theory thing or
a matching problem but you know I got
cooler job offers like civil investment
that was a big deal I actually have a
video that talks about Citadel so yeah
check check that out if you want oh yeah
by the way at this point I started
knowing how to crack the interview I
mean I'm not gonna talk about how
exactly
what I did to get the offers because I
already made videos of that and I also I
have a whole course on it called Tech
interview procom which is really good I
mean you should check it out now because
there's a 50% off currently for Labor
Day week it's it's pretty much a video
course that teaches you exactly how to
ace an interview and there's like a
private Facebook group where we answer
questions and there's like live Q&A
where we host like every two weeks so
yeah definitely check it out if you're
preparing to interview it's really good
I'm super proud of this course and yeah
I hope I hope that you guys would enjoy
it too but yeah check it out
this is my third co-op and now I you
know I got the hang a bit but I wanted
to go into pure software companies right
like LinkedIn Facebook Google those kind
of things so I didn't want to do Finance
tech anymore so now this time I applied
to my dream companies so as you can see
the offers I got I got Coursera Coursera
was good III I liked the interview the
interview was pretty good as you can see
I I got rejected by Google you know my
dream company got rejected and then
LinkedIn I got an offer there which was
great I made a video about it on how I
got an internship ellington you could
should check that out and then Microsoft
for embedded systems I did not get it
but I got the software development
engineering role it makes sense I didn't
know anything about embedded systems I
had no idea how I got the interview I
thought I did decently well but but yeah
preparing not cuz because they rejected
me
once again applied to Palantir
technologies but i didn't get it this
time I was right they actually asked me
the same question but I still failed and
then tinder you know this was the first
time they were hiring interns from
Waterloo and I got the offer they only
picked one
I remember cuz I did the interview I
even talked to the CTO
wait what happened oh yeah remember like
I had a porn Dora yeah so I made porn
Dora but like I didn't list it here
exactly on my resume cuz
we did I linked incorporate actually
yeah I did I did I think I did put in my
porn Dora
project but I called it like video
streaming site or something like that
but yeah because I did that project I
learned a lot about uws you know so
anything with like auto-scaling stuff
you know using s3 you see the ends and
stuff like that because it was very like
video intensive kind of things so I
think I really impressed the CTO because
I knew a lot of these scrappy
technologies that you usually use when
you build a project from scratch so I
yeah I think the CTO liked me so that
was great
and then also the recruiter was super
cute but yeah I don't know if she
imagined she watches my videos they'll
be great
shy messager Oscar anyways and I also
got the Yelp offer that was pretty cool
next I have no idea what next is so
that's pretty much it for the coop
because after that I actually dropped
out of co-op the reason is because I
didn't want to do PD which is a
professional development you had to
write an essay about the work that
you've done or something like that and I
really really didn't want to do it so I
just dropped out of the whole co-op
system and I just found jobs myself I
went to Facebook and then after that I
went to Microsoft I went to Facebook for
data science at Microsoft for product
management program management and yeah I
just got referral didn't interview and
you know got the offer I didn't really
take the chance to interview a bunch of
places which I do regret for full time
when I got out of school I think I
applied to a lot of different companies
too I got rejected from Palantir again
yeah I was just never able to go to
Palantir I got rejected by Facebook rpm
for proper management I got rejected by
Google APM associate program associate
product manager yeah so that's pretty
much it and then the offers I got was
like BuzzFeed for data science because I
want to get famous and then I went there
I already had a return offer for
Facebook I had a return offer for
Microsoft I ended up going to what's it
called again at BuzzFeed and then I mean
I did get a few offers for mice recent
switch from data science to software so
the offers that I got were oh sorry
about that the camera the Callen was
doing something weird I guess it got cut
off yeah anyways so that's about it now
to the quick updates I just want to
thank each and every one of you who
donated to the fundraiser to my
fundraiser for Mental Health America and
yeah in case you forgot I was giving out
these corgis for everyone who donated
and we passed our goal the goal was two
thousand dollars and we passed it and I
still have a lot of corgis left so I'm
just gonna increase the goal to three
thousand dollars now but yeah I'm super
happy about it the turnout was super
great and you guys are doing this for a
great cause so thank you so much for
donating so I rarely talk about my
personal life but I guess I'll tell you
this I actually have a roommate she is a
high school teacher teaching
environmental science I have massive
respect for her she's doing something
great she's teaching something very
important and she teaches me all the
time - I'm basically a man-child and she
helps me become less of a man-child
so I really really appreciate her today
I wanted to surprise her by giving her a
new MacBook Pro provided by brilliant
org thank you so much for sending that
so thanks brilliant org for sponsoring
this video and sending this MacBook Pro
for her and brilliant org in case you
don't know it is a website that
publishes daily challenge every day on
stem the site is extremely sleek and
they have over 50 interactive courses
which makes learning these concepts so
much easier I actually use them when I
prep for my data science interviews
because their probability section was
really really good this website is a
great complement to universities because
you get to practice all these things
that you learned in theory in class
and then you could finally apply it to
these questions for example me myself
I'm more of a doer than a listener I
have to try after practice I have to do
things and I wish that I had brilliant
org when I was in school because I would
be able to practice my questions I would
able to apply my knowledge to see if I
actually understand so if you're
interested don't forget to go on
brilliant
org slash coma and the first 200 people
will get 20% off all right back to my
roommate so I asked her to talk about
water bottle usages and I there was
basically an excuse to film it to film
her reaction but I mean the thing that
she says is really important so you
should listen to it but this is what
happened for the short break I want to
talk to you about something quite
important and it's about water balls no
I have my roommate here and she's gonna
be talking about something really
important so um about water bottles
right mm-hmm okay so well chances are
you drink out of water bottles you know
sometime in your life and more likely
than not it's probably a plastic water
bottle and unfortunately that's probably
not the best thing to do for our
environment of course because we all
live on this planet and we share it and
plastic is made out of oil which is you
know a fossil feel that unfortunately we
don't have very much of left in our
world and we you know don't want to run
out of it and we have a lot of other
applications for it okay so plastic
water bottles you know doesn't always
end up where you think it might when
you're done using it so what is one easy
trick to prevent this issue um probably
be a good idea to get a reusable water
bottle no she mm-hmm
so it's really important which is why I
also have my own water bottle so as you
can see using reusable water bottle is
very very important that's why I always
use a reusable water bottle wait those
are plastic bottles
oh yeah that's dumb thank you for doing
this video so I have a little surprise
for you close your eyes it's a little
gift for you all right you can open your
eyes this is yours
this is sponsored by thank you so much
for providing this MacBook Pro which I
could give to my roommate because she's
a great teacher it's George Wright I
know it's not just food I was hoping for
a better reaction yeah this is a disease
yours for all your hard work
why all the good cause I'm really
confused right now I mean brilliant sent
us a laptop so since I have already
three of them I don't okay here's how
you were supposed to react look no
[ __ ] look no no no no I can't accept
this no way so let's do that again
[Music]